containers have drastically changed the
workflow of many developers and so you
might wonder how do I run containers on
Google cloud platform in this video
we'll review three ways you can run your
containers on GCP
[Music]
while the concepts underlying containers
have been around for many years docker
kubernetes and an entire ecosystem of
products and best practices have emerged
in the last few years
enabling many different kinds of
applications to be containerized as a
developer containers give you a lot of
freedom by letting you package an app
with all of its dependencies into an
easy to move package the solutions for
running containers and GCP very
essentially in how much of the
underlying infrastructure is exposed the
first way you can run a container on GCP
is to use google kubernetes engine or
gke
as the inventor of cuban ladies google
quite naturally offers a fully managed
cuba days service taking care of
scheduling and scaling your containers
while monitoring their health and state
getting your code to production on gke
can be as simple as creating a container
deployment with the cluster being
provisioned on the fly once running gke
clusters are secure by default highly
available monitored and they run on
Google clouds high speed network they
can also be fine-tuned for zonal and
regional locations and can use specific
machine types with optional GPUs or TP
use gk clusters also offer hassle-free
operations with auto scaling auto repair
of failing nodes and auto upgrade to the
latest stable version of kubernetes gke
is also a key component of anthos google
clouds Enterprise hybrid and multi cloud
platform with anthos you can also
migrate existing VMs directly into
containers and move your workloads
freely between on-premises and cloud
environments such as GCB what if you
could focus on building your stateless
app not on writing llamó files and still
deliver code packaged in a container the
second way you can deploy your
containers on Google cloud is with cloud
run this gives you the benefits of both
containers and serverless there is no
cluster or infrastructure to provision
or manage and cloud run automatically
scales any of your stateless containers
creating a cloud run service with your
container only requires selecting a
location giving it a name and setting
authentication requirements cloud run
supports multiple requests per container
and it works with any Lang
which any library any binary and even
any based darker image the result is
service with true pay for usage the
ability to scale to zero and full
out-of-the-box monitoring logging and
error reporting because cloud run is
built using the key native open source
project which offers a service
abstraction on top of Cuban ATS you can
have your own private hosting
environment and deploy the exact same
container workload on cloud run for
anthos in GCP or on prem the third
option for deploying your containers is
straight to Google compute engine or GCE
that's right you can leverage your
familiar virtual machine environment to
run your containers this means using
your existing workflow and tools without
requiring your team to ramp up on all
thanks cloud native when creating a GC
virtual machine the containers section
will let you specify the image you'd
like to use as well as a few important
options when you get to the boot disk
section the suggested virtual machine OS
is something called a container
optimized OS an operating system
optimized for running darker containers
and maintained by Google this operating
system image comes with a docker run
time pre-installed thus enabling you to
bring up your darker container at the
same time you create your virtual
machine but it also lacks most of what
you expect to find in a typical Linux
distribution such as a package manager
and many other binaries this means a log
down environment that ensures a smaller
attack surface keeping your container
runtime as safe as possible the great
thing about running your containers on
compute engine is that you can still
create scalable services using managed
instance groups as they offer auto
scaling auto healing rolling updates
multi zone deployment and load balancing
for the compute instances where do these
container images come from where do we
store them how do i person them and how
do i district' access to them the answer
lies in Google container registry or GCR
which is a private by default container
registry that runs on GCP with
consistent uptime and across multiple
regions you can push pull and manage
images in GCR from any
system VM instance or your own hardware
and maintain control over who can access
view and download those images not also
how you can conveniently deploy to all
three runtimes we've discussed straight
from container registry deploy to cloud
run to container engine and to compute
engine container registry works with
popular containers delivery systems such
as cloud build spinnaker or Jenkins to
automatically build containers on code
or tag changes to repository finally
container analysis scans container
images stored in the registry for known
vulnerabilities and keeps you informed
so that you can review and address
issues before deployment google cloud
offers you three solid ways to run your
containers ranging from a fully managed
kubernetes environment to a truly
serverless platform pick the solution
that works best for you and start
deploying your containerized workloads
today consider trying some free code
labs linked in the description below to
explore these products and look forward
to upcoming episodes and more overviews
if you like this video please like
subscribe comment share and look forward
to more GCP essentials videos
[Music]